[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
guten Abend es vergeht kaum ein Tag an
dem der neue Verteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius nicht im bundeswehrparka vor
einem Panzer steht anders als seine
Vorgängerin versucht er in flectan
maximale Nähe zur Truppe zu
demonstrieren allerdings hört er auch
bei jedem Besuch die gleiche Klage die
deutsche Armee kaputt gespart schlecht
ausgerüstet nur bedingt abwehrbereit und
jetzt soll sie auch noch Waffen an die
Ukraine abgeben Thomas Reichert
berichtet über einen
Verteidigungsminister auf der Suche nach
mehr Geld und Material
das ist einer der Panzer um die es geht
einer der 14 die Deutschland demnächst
in die Ukraine liefert der Leopard 2
gehört zum Panzerbataillon in Augustdorf
in Nordrhein-Westfalen zudem der neue
Verteidigungsminister heute einfliegt
Boris Pistorius muss eine Truppe die von
sich selbst sagt sie stehen mehr oder
weniger blank da erklären warum es
wichtig ist 14 Leopard aus dem knappen
Bestand abzugeben und damit noch blanker
zu sein das ist für die Ukraine gut
verstärkt die Ukraine ganz sicher aber
es schmeckt natürlich die Einsatz und
übungsfähigkeit und wir werden
unsererseits alles tun um die Lücken die
das gerissen hat vorübergehend oder
reißen wird und schnell wie möglich zu
schließen es ist ein großes Versprechen
das Bataillon das Pistorius dann auf
einem Leopard mitnimmt muss von der Zeit
32 Panzer nicht nur 14 an die Ukraine
abgeben acht weitere sind mit Besatzung
noch in Litauen um die NATO ostflank zu
schützen in Augustdorf lässt sich
besichtigen wie Russlands kriegt die
Bundeswehr an ihre Grenzen bringt der
bittere ist Zustand sieht so aus von den
290 Leopard Panzern in den Bataillonen
der Bundeswehr sind keine 90
einsatzbereit auch in Augustdorf sind 5
Leopard Defekt neue Panzer wie Pistorius
die verspricht könnten wohl frühestens
in drei Jahren geliefert werden wenn er
das wirklich realisieren will dann muss
er in der Regierung mit dem Parlament
auch sprechen wie man Rahmenbedingungen
verändert denn er muss in den nächsten
Monaten bestellen damit diese diese
Ersatz in dieser Legislaturperiode noch
realisiert werden kann der Truppe in
Augustdorf fehlt es nicht nur ein
Panzern und Munition sondern wie überall
in der Bundeswehr an viele mehr
historius hat klar gemacht dass die 100
Milliarden Sondervermögen aus seiner
Sicht nicht reichen werden aber für
schnellen panzerersatz braucht ihr die
Rüstungsindustrie die macht klar sie
braucht langfristige Verträge was wir
nicht machen dürfen wir dürfen nicht nur
ein Jahr denken und wir müssen was
ändern bei der Budgetierung denn wenn
Sie heute fünf bis zehn Jahre
Planungssicherheit haben brauchen Sie
natürlich auch für fünf bis zehn Jahre
Geld und das hat das abente heute nicht
ja der Prozess ist hier limitiert und
ich denke das muss angepasst werden die
Gespräche mit der Rüstungsindustrie
genau dazu liefen seit dieser Woche sagt
Pistorius heute und da sind sie ein paar
konkrete Arbeitsaufträge erwachsen auf
beiden Seiten an denen wir jetzt
arbeiten und dann geht es hoffentlich
sehr schnell voran es war jedenfalls
sehr sehr gute Gespräche die Hoffnung
machen dass wir da jetzt mehr Speed
reinkriegen in die Frage
speed and this ist etwas wofür besonders
die Bürokratie in Pistorius Ministerium
bislang eher weniger bekannt war
vor etwas über drei Jahren infizierte
sich ein junger Mann bei München mit
einem Virus von dem wir in Deutschland
bis dahin gedacht hatten dass es
hauptsächlich China betreffe wir so
dachten wir in Deutschland würden mit
Corona fertig werden wir waren ja gut
gerüstet mit unserem hervorragenden
modernen Gesundheitssystem drei Jahre
später wissen wir es kam anders wir
wissen ebenfalls dass Virologen
Politiker und auch wir Journalisten mit
manchem falsch schlagen Sibylle Basler
schaut zurück und blickt nach vorne auf
mögliche Lehren aus der corona-pandemie
die Firma Webasto in Gauting hier fing
alles an mit Patient 1 dem ersten
Menschen in Deutschland bei dem Corona
nachgewiesen wurde drei Jahre ist es her
nach dem ersten Schock sagt Holger
Engelmann habe sich einiges verändert
beginnen sicherlich vorsichtiger
miteinander um es ist öfters so dass
sicherlich Kollegen zu Hause bleiben
wenn Sie das Gefühl haben dass sie
vielleicht eine Erkältung oder eine
Grippe oder vielleicht sogar Corona
haben da ist eine höhere Sensibilität
eine höhere Sensibilität im Umgang aber
auch eine neue Form der Arbeit hat sich
etabliert statt Büro Homeoffice von Bund
und Ländern beschlossen in den eigenen
vier Wänden arbeiten flexibel mobil
vieles geht plötzlich in der Not muss
gehen in der corona-krise ging es darum
das Schiff am Fahren zu halten die
Wirtschaft am Laufen zu halten die
Beschäftigen den Jobs wir haben auch
gelernt dass
Dinge gehen die vorher sehr langsam
liefen
doch das hat seinen Preis Lockdown
Kurzarbeit corona-hilfen das kostet was
lange nicht geht die Nähe zueinander
statt gemeinsam einsam wie bei rixer
Straße und ihrem Mann Peter lange durfte
sie ihn nicht im Seniorenheim besuchen
wir waren wie zwei Königskinder das
Wasser war eben viel zu tief aber man
konnte nichts dagegen machen auch heute
darf sie sich eigentlich nur mit
negativtest und Maske ihrem Mann nähern
das sieht eine Regelung des bundesweiten
Infektionsschutzgesetzes vor die Anfang
April ausläuft doch da regt sich bei der
80-jährigen Widerstand wenn ich jetzt
negativ getestet worden bin hier dann
setze ich sie natürlich nicht auf weil
ich finde das ist doppelt gemoppelt dann
die verlorene Zeit sagt sie kann man
nicht mehr zurückholen
corona-regeln in Schulen Ländersache und
die reagieren mit unterschiedlichen
Maßnahmen vom Homeschooling über
Notbetreuung alles ist möglich und das
hinterlässt Spuren viele junge klagen
über psychische Probleme Zukunftsängste
Isolation plötzlich nicht treffen zu
können plötzlich rausgehen zu können und
ich habe so das Gefühl ich habe die
letzten Jahre irgendwie bisschen
verpasst und jetzt ihre kehr in die
Normalität weg mit der Maske im
öffentlichen Räumen ab heute Nacht
bundesweit auch im Fernverkehr an die
neue Freiheit müssen sich manche erst
noch gewöhnen
ob das mal gut ist ich weiß es nicht ich
finde es falsch aber ich respektiere
natürlich alles und ich kann sie ja auch
zum Schutz für mich tragen damit muss
man leben wir müssen lernen damit
umzugehen so ist es wie überall im Leben
auch Peter Auernhammer ist froh dass
wieder eine gewisse Normalität einkehrt
in Hochzeiten von Corona standen bis zu
100 Menschen vor seiner Apotheke
Schlange und Masken oder Test zu
bekommen dazu noch das wirrwa um die
corona-regeln das habe genervt in Bayern
was da was ich in Baden-Württemberg
nicht darf und umgekehrt das haben die
Leute eben nicht verstanden und ich
glaube das war hoffentlich das was man
daraus lernt dass man Zukunft sowas
bundeseinheitlich Regeln muss
drei Jahre corona-regeln eine blaue Zeit
liegt hinter uns manches ist gut
gelaufen aber es hat auch einige Narben
hinterlassen
darüber wollen wir reden mit einem der
die corona-politik in Deutschland
entscheidend geprägt hat und jetzt
amtierender Gesundheitsminister ist
guten Abend nach Berlin Herr Lauterbach
guten Abend wenn sie zurückschauen auf
die letzten drei Jahre was waren die
größten Fehler die die Politik oder die
sie in der Pandemie gemacht haben ich
möchte jetzt mal sagen es sind nicht nur
Fehler gemacht worden sondern insgesamt
ist Deutschland natürlich im Vergleich
zu anderen Ländern die eine ähnlich alte
Bevölkerung gehabt haben gut durch die
Pandemie gekommen wären nicht so viele
Todesfälle beklagen müssen wir haben
auch nicht so viele Infektionen gehabt
somit sind auch viele lonkovitfälle
vermieden worden die sonst
möglicherweise nicht ausgehalten werden
somit ist also muss ja eingeräumt werden
es hat Fehler gegeben aber im Großen und
Ganzen sind wir besser durchgekommen als
viele Länder mit ähnlichen Problemen
einen falschen Schwerpunkt gegeben also
bei der Kontakt Reduzierung da sind
einige Länder dazu übergegangen haben
mehr die Kontakte in den Betrieben
reduziert wir haben stark die Kontakte
reduziert bei den Kindern insbesondere
bei den Kita-Kindern und bei den
Schulkindern das war sicherlich im
Nachhinein betrachtet weil die
Studienlage war damals noch nicht so
klar wie ansteckend sind Kita-Kinder ja
anstecken sind Schulkinder aber das war
im Nachhinein betrachtet aus meiner
Sicht etwas was man so nicht also
wiederholen sollte da war die der
Schwerpunkt vielleicht etwas falsch
gesetzt wir haben nachher dann die Dinge
besser gemacht werden nachher dann die
Kinder sehr regelmäßig in den Klassen
getestet und konnten die Schule offen
halten das hätten wir viel früher machen
können das wäre sicherlich richtig
gewesen auch hätte man in den Schulen
gepulte PCR Tests einsetzen können dann
hätte man noch genauer die Schulen
überwachen können dann werden noch
weniger Unterricht ausgefallen da ist
sicherlich also etwas aufzuarbeiten das
war ein Fehler es gibt eine eine
wissenschaftliche Studie der
cockrain-gesellschaft die zumindest
Zweifel daran sät dass das Tragen von
Masken in epidemiologischer Hinsicht
überhaupt einen Effekt hat wann also die
Regeln der letzten drei Jahre Quatsch
nein also so kann man diese Studie auch
nicht interpretieren das ist eine gute
Studie zum maximalen Wirkungsgrad von
Masken aber es ist unstrittig durch
viele andere Studien die es gegeben hat
das Masken wirken das ist übrigens auch
die Voraussetzung unserer Arbeit in den
Kliniken also im OP wird eine Maske
getragen weil man also Menschen nicht
infizieren will und so weiter und so
fort somit also das jetzt noch einmal
diese ganz alte Debatte geführt wird wir
haben Masken überhaupt gehört oder nicht
so stark ist die Studie dann nicht dass
sie dieses Gewicht tragen könnte
unbestritten ist aber ja dass der Staat
sich massiv in das Leben der Bürger
eingemischt hat Bußgelder für Masken
Muffel verhängt Ausgangssperren
verordnet impfnachweise gefordert was
davon würden sie aus heutiger Sicht
sagen war überzogen
es gab natürlich Dinge die überzogen
waren zum Teil war ja zum Beispiel auch
also das Ausgehen also an der freien
Luft nicht mehr erlaubt und also der
Parkspaziergang war zum Teil ein
Geschenk gerade in Bayern hat man sehr
viel zum Teil dann gemacht was nicht
wissenschaftlich gesichert war das war
übrigens auch damals nicht
wissenschaftlich gesichert also einiges
haben sich die Studien später anders
dargestellt da ist man dazu nachträglich
zu einer anderen Bewertung gekommen aber
diese drakonischen Maßnahmen
ausgebote also Masken tragen an der
freien Luft
Kinderspielplätze draußen abregeln und
dergleichen das sind Dinge gewesen die
würde man heute nicht mehr machen die
waren aber auch damals umstritten und
nie durch die Studien wirklich gut
gedeckt sie haben das ja schon
eingeräumt dass sie Schließung von
Schulen und Kindergärten ein Fehler war
oder zu hart war jetzt brauchen aber
viele Kinder und Jugendliche
Therapieplätze und Hilfe und Bildung und
die gibt ja auch nicht das stimmt aber
ich persönlich arbeite zum Beispiel mit
dem
Bundesgesundheitsministerium mit dem
Team an also der Verbesserung der
Versorgung von Kindern an allen Ebenen
beispielsweise wir sorgen dafür dass die
Lieferengpässe gerade bei Kinderarzt
Heilmittel besorgt also habe ich
beseitigt werden die Kinderkliniken
haben eine endbudgetierung zwischen 80
und 100% des Budgets bereits gesehen und
wir arbeiten jetzt auch an einer
Regelung wo es sonderbedarfe geben soll
also zulasse Zulassungen für
sonderbedarfe so dass insbesondere die
psychotherapeutische also Versorgung von
Kindern besser dargestellt werden kann
da wird vieles jetzt nachgeholt mit Elan
das ist unsere Pflicht die Kinder haben
am meisten unter der Pandemie gelitten
und müssen jetzt besonders gut versorgt
werden
die Pandemie hat uns vor Augen geführt
dass unser Gesundheitssystem noch viele
andere Mängel hat welche Lehren haben
Sie daraus gezogen für die Zukunft
wir haben zum einen also einen massiven
pflegemangel zu erwarten daher muss die
Pflege attraktiver gemacht werden wir
müssen da bessere Ausbildungs-
zum Teil in der Existenz bedroht da
haben wir gerade eine große Reform vor
das ist glaube ich die größte
krankenhausreform seit 20 Jahren wo die
Krankenhäuser aus dieser ökonomischen
Spirale herauskommen können die
Krankenhäuser müssen ja jetzt einen
fahren nach dem anderen machen und so
billig wie möglich um überhaupt Ihr
Budget zu bekommen da sollen die
Krankenhäuser einfach Geld bekommen für
die da sein Fürsorge dass eine wichtige
Wort einige andere kommen dazu also das
haben sie schon erwähnt also mehr
Pflegepersonal was ist mit der
Digitalisierung wird es auch in der
nächsten Pandemie Gesundheitsämter geben
die Faxe schicken das hoffe ich nicht
und die Digitalisierung wird auch in
diesem Jahr noch mit zwei großen
Gesetzen nach vorne gebracht also
sogenanntes digitalgesetz für die
elektronische Patientenakte und ein
Gesundheitsdaten nutzungsgesetz dass man
die Daten die man hat auch
zusammenführen kann und für
Forschungszwecke auswerten kann also in
der Digitalisierung kommt ein großer
schob nach vorne also Digitalisierung
krankenhausreform dann besser Stellung
der Kollege Lieferengpässe bei den
Arzneimitteln das sind alleine vier
große Reformen die in den nächsten
Monaten kommen werden unser
Gesundheitssystem war sehr viel fragiler
sehr viel verletzlicher als wir gedacht
haben und wir haben noch Glück gehabt
dass die Pandemie dann zum Schluss durch
die ionicon Varianten also sich mehr
oder weniger ein Stück weit selbst
beschenkt hat aber unser
Gesundheitssystem muss er stark werden
mehr Glück als Verstand sagen manche das
war Karl Lauterbach der
Bundesgesundheitsminister aus Berlin
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch ich
danke Ihnen
das Gespräch haben wir aus Termingründen
vor zwei Stunden aufgezeichnet und hier
geht es weiter mit den Nachrichten und
Gundula Gosse die Ukraine setzt große
Hoffnungen auf das Gipfeltreffen mit der
EU ab morgen in Kiel Präsident silenski
erwartet Entscheidungen hofft auf neue
Militärhilfen und Unterstützung auf dem
Weg in die EU das sagte er in seiner
abendlichen videoansprache seit Juni ist
die Ukraine
EU-Beitrittskandidat Österreichs
Bundespräsident van der Bellen sagte
selenski in Kiew weitere humanitäre
Hilfe zu
verbunden mit dem von der Ukraine
angestrebten EU-Beitritt sind Auflagen
bei der Korruptionsbekämpfung hier
kündigte silensky weitere unbesetzungen
von Führungspositionen an in der Ukraine
wurden außerdem mehrere Razzien gegen
der Korruption verdächtigte
Behördenvertreter Oligarchen und
ehemalige Politiker durchgeführt
Bundestags Vizepräsidentin
Göring-Eckardt befürwortet eine klare
EU-Perspektive für die Ukraine darüber
sowie über rüstungshilfen und
Wiederaufbau sprach sie in Kiew mit
Ministerpräsident schmidhalle mehr dazu
in einem Interview später im heute
journal Update um 0:30 Uhr
in Großbritannien haben sich nach
Gewerkschaftsangaben mehr als eine halbe
Million Beschäftigte des öffentlichen
Dienstes am größten Streik seit Jahren
beteiligt allein in London legten
zehntausende Regierungsmitarbeiter
Lehrkräfte und Lokführer die Arbeit
nieder und gingen auf die Straßen sie
fordern deutlich höhere Löhne und
bessere Arbeitsbedingungen zuletzt
stiegen die Verbraucherpreise um gut
zehn Prozent das Lohnangebot der
konservativen Regierung liegt klar
darunter auch der Gesundheitsdienst NHS
kündigte Streiks an
zum zweiten Jahrestag des Putsches in
Myanmar hat das militär-regime den
Ausnahmezustand in dem südostasiatischen
Land um ein weiteres halbes Jahr
verlängert als stillen Protest gegen die
Macht Übernahme des Militärs blieben in
yangong und Mandalai viele Geschäfte
geschlossen und die Menschen zu Hause
seit dem Staatsstreich geht die Armee
brutal gegen Proteste und Widerstand der
Bevölkerung vor
ich hasse die Tatsache dass es fünf
schwarze Männer waren die das einem
anderen schwarzen Mann angetan haben so
die Mutter von Teil Nickels in einem
Fernsehinterview ihr Sohn 29 Jahre alt
war Anfang Januar bei einer
Verkehrskontrolle in Memphis von fünf
Polizisten so brutal zusammengeschlagen
worden dass er drei Tage später im
Krankenhaus starb immer wieder machen
Polizisten in den USA mit solchen
Gewaltorgien von sich reden das Risiko
von einem Polizisten getötet zu werden
ist für schwarze fast dreimal so hoch
wie für weiße und hinterher ist die
Politik jedes Mal betroffen auch heute
bei der Beerdigung von Teil Nickels
Claudia Bates berichtet
für sie ist es der schwerste Gang die
Familie von tyreen Nickels begleitet von
Prominenten Bürgerrechtlern und auch
Vizepräsidentin Carla Harris ist
gekommen um ihre Solidarität zu zeigen
jede Mutter die ein Kind zur Welt bringt
betet wenn Sie Ihr Kind im Arm hält zu
Gott dass dieser Körper dieses Leben
sicher sein möge solange es lebt
wird deutlich Rassismus sei das Problem
und eine Polizeireform dringend
notwendig
[Applaus]
die denken dass wir für einen oder zwei
Tage wütend sind und uns dann anderem
zuwenden aber manche von uns glauben
daran dass der Traum wahr werden muss
einige von uns werden kämpfen bis es
neue Gesetze gibt ich weiß nicht wann
und ich weiß nicht wie aber wir werden
nicht aufhören bevor wir euch zur
Rechenschaft ziehen und das System
ändern
der mag erschütternde Schrei nach seiner
Mutter hat das Land getroffen
Tyree Nickels ist nur zwei Minuten von
ihrem Haus entfernt als er von der
Polizei gestoppt wird er ist unbewaffnet
und wehrlos als die fünf Polizisten
brutal auf ihn einschlagen kurz darauf
stirbt der 29-Jährige im Krankenhaus die
Polizisten wurden entlassen und
angeklagt ihre Einheit aufgelöst jedes
Jahr sterben in den USA mehr als tausend
Menschen bei Konfrontationen mit der
Polizei auch schwarze Polizisten sind
nicht gefeit vor rassistischen
Stereotypen die in der Gesellschaft
verankert sind zeigen Studien
es gibt einfach gegen den die für die
Polizei als Kriegsgebiete gelten und
dort scheint alles erlaubt wir müssen es
aber etwas differenzierter sehen um die
Wurzeln des Rassismus zu beseitigen es
geht nicht um schwarze und weiße
Polizisten wir brauchen Polizisten die
lernen jeden Menschen zu respektieren
doch die Ausbildung ist dezentral
organisiert es gibt rund 18.000
unabhängige polizeiabteilungen das
Training dauert durchschnittlich nur
rund vier Monate und ist vor allem aufs
schießen ausgerichtet weil sie immer
damit rechnen müssen dass ihr gegenüber
bewaffnet ist nach dem Tod von George
floy 2020 dem ein Polizist auf dem Hals
kniete bis er starb ging es im Kongress
um eine Polizeireform aber die Parteien
konnten sich nicht einigen das Gesetz
scheiterte
Vizepräsidentin der Vereinigten Staaten
fordere ich dass der Kongress das George
floyd-gesetz jetzt verabschiedet Joe
Biden wird es unterschreiben
aber das sagen jetzt alle es darf nie
wieder passieren und sie werden es auch
nach dem nächsten Mal wieder sagen
in der Klimapolitik macht der
amerikanische Präsident Joe Biden
eigentlich genau das was sich Europa
wünscht er hatte ein Paket von knapp 340
Milliarden Euro aufgelegt um grüne
Technologien zu fördern aber leider sind
diese Staatshilfen für Unternehmen
reserviert die in den USA produzieren
europa bleibt außen vor und so geht hier
die Angst um das Firmen in die USA
abwandern und der Standort EU in Gefahr
sein könnte brüssel will dagegenhalten
eu-kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen schlägt nun ebenfalls mehr
staatliche Hilfen für europäische
Unternehmen vor doch die Idee hat einen
Schönheitsfehler nicht alle EU-Länder
haben gleich viel Geld um die heimische
Industrie zu fördern Florian neuhahn
über den transatlantischen
Subventionswettlauf
egal wo man hinschaut eine Richtung
steht längst fest elektrisch fahren ist
die Zukunft ob hier in den USA
hier in China oder natürlich mitten in
Europa eine Frage ist dagegen ziemlich
offen wir diese E-Autos künftig
produziert wer wirtschaftlich das Rennen
gewinnt die USA der US-Präsident legt im
Sommer vor ein mega Klima
subventionspaket mit vielem Haken Geld
nur für Elektroautos die in seinem Land
produziert werden seitdem sorgen sie
sich in Europa dass die heimische
Industrie abwandert heute ein erster
Konter nicht ohne vorab zu betonen
wir begrüßen dieses Paket das ist eine
gute Nachricht wir haben ja immer gesagt
der Kampf gegen den Klimawandel ist ein
muss
ein muss das aber sei für Europa auch
jetzt mit und eigene Firmen hier zu
halten künftig sollen die
Mitgliedstaaten daher leichter als
bisher Finanzhilfen für grüne
Investitionen zahlen dürfen klingt
einleuchtend auf den ersten Blick und
schwierig nach einem zweiten auf die
Statistik
672 Milliarden Euro zahlten nationale
Regierungen seit Beginn des
ukrainekriegs an Subventionen mehr als
die Hälfte davon deutsche Mittel für
deutsche Firmen ein weiteres Viertel aus
Frankreich der Rest Europas kam da nicht
mit
es kann aber eben nicht sein dass manche
Mitgliedstaaten gerade sehr sehr viel
Geld in die grüne Transformation Pumpen
was an sich gut ist aber dann andere
Mitgliedsstaaten der Europäischen Union
leer ausgehen weil sie einfach nicht das
Geld haben um den Binnenmarkt in der
Europäischen Union nicht zu
fragmentieren brauchen wir deshalb auch
gemeinsam europäischen Mittel keine
Spaltung stattdessen neues EU-Geld das
wäre ganz nach Ihrem Geschmack die
kommissionspräsidentin würde gern neue
Mittel verteilen verrät heute aber
außerdem bekannten Titel
souveränitätsfonds weder woher das Geld
kommen sollen noch wie viel ihr
vorschwebt ohnehin müssten einige noch
überzeugt werden ein voran der deutsche
Finanzminister wie wie mastend enter wir
dürfen jetzt keinen Wettbewerb starten
wer mehr Subventionen zahlen kann es
liegt schon genügend Geld auf dem Tisch
ich bin nicht überzeugt dass wir
irgendeine Form weiterer Fördermittel
brauchen
funding instruments
grüne dafür FDP dagegen der
Bundeskanzler heute zurückhaltend
positiv die Vorschläge so Scholz gingen
in eine richtige Richtung Europa will
nicht hinterher hinken im Kampf um grüne
zukunftsindustrie doch um den richtigen
Weg bringen sie noch in Berlin wie in
Europa insgesamt
und hier geht es weiter mit Nachrichten
aus der Wirtschaft und mit Gundula im
Saarland soll die weltweit größte Fabrik
für Halbleiter entstehen ein
US-Chiphersteller will investieren
Bundeskanzler Scholz und
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck haben sich
diesen Termin im kleinen Ensdorf nicht
nehmen lassen Frank Bethmann was
verspricht sich die Bundesregierung von
den Milliardenprojekt naja vor allem das
Deutschland und damit natürlich die
heimische Industrie unabhängiger und
krisenresistenter werden Halbleiter eine
Schlüsseltechnologie vom Kühlschrank bis
zum Auto überall drin und wir haben es
während der Pandemie erlebt wie anfällig
ganze Industriezweig geworden als
insbesondere aus Fernost keine Chips
mehr kamen Bänder standen still weil die
Lieferketten unterbrochen waren vor
diesem Hintergrund ist das also eine
strategisch wichtige Ansiedlung die sich
die Bundesregierung auch etwas kosten
lässt mit Subventionen von 20 bis 25%
der Investitionssumme die bei rund 3,5
Milliarden Euro liegen soll rechnet der
US-Konzern wolfspeed der auf dem Gelände
eines alten Kraftwerkes eines der
weltweit größten Werke für Halbleiter
aus Siliziumcarbid bauen will solche
Halbleiter gelten als gamechanger für
die Elektromobilität insbesondere weil
diese Chips für größere Reichweiten bei
Elektroautos sorgen also wir reden über
eine schlüsselinvestition die wenn die
Fabrik einmal fertig ist mehr als 600
neue Jobs bringen soll
hutsamen Zinsentscheidung der
US-Notenbank vor zwei Stunden was
bedeutet das für die EZB morgen die
amerikanische Notenbank erhöht die
Leitzinsen um weitere 0,25% Punkte
gerechnet wird damit dass die EZB morgen
ebenfalls weiter an der Zinsschraube
dreht und die Leitzinsen um 0,5% Punkte
anheben wird vielen Dank
das Polizeigesetz von
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ist teilweise
verfassungswidrig das
Bundesverfassungsgericht erklärte
mehrere Vorschriften zu heimlichen
Überwachungsmaßnahmen durch die Polizei
sei nicht genau genug und
unverhältnismäßig es geht unter anderem
um den Einsatz von V-Leuten und die
heimliche Wohnraumüberwachung die
Regelungen müssen jetzt bis Ende des
Jahres überarbeitet werden zum Sport RB
Leipzig steht im Viertelfinale des
DFB-Pokals nach dem 3:1 Sieg am Abend
gegen Hoffenheim einen Spielbericht zum
anderen Achtelfinale Mainz 05 gegen
Bayern München sehen sie später eben
heute journal Update
wir haben die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten ohne Gewähr 620 34
36 40 49 Superzahl 5 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf Lotto zdf.de und im ZDF
Text
Papst franziskus hat in Kongos
Hauptstadt Kinshasa erneut ein Ende der
Gewalt der verfeindeten Milizen
gefordert bei einer Messe mit mehr als
einer Million Gläubigen rief der Papst
eindringlich zufrieden auf im Namen
Gottes verurteilte er Gewalt Massaker
und Vergewaltigungen bei einem Treffen
mit Opfern von Gräueltaten aus dem Osten
der Demokratischen Republik Kongo
reagierte franziskus erschüttert ab
Freitag will er im Südsudan für Frieden
Verben
das war es von uns hier geht's gleich
weiter mit dem Ausland schon mal ein
Thema darin das kleine Litauen und seine
große Angst vor Russland
und um 0 Uhr meldet sich also
wolfsschmiese mit unserem
heute-journal-update Ihnen einen schönen
Abend und bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die Tendenz zu
warmer Januar Monate setzt sich weiter
fort und der vergangene Januar war zu
warm fällt unter die zehn wärmsten
überhaupt hat eine Temperaturabweichung
von 4 Grad über den gesamten Monat ja
der Monat Januar ist auch nicht mehr das
was er früher war der eismonat oder war
teilweise zu nass im Norden vor allem
hier total über 200% der normalen
Regenmenge und ganz im Süden warst
deutlich zu trocken da kommt jetzt
kräftiger Schneefall auf zumindest in
den höheren Lagen zumindest an den Alpen
etwas oberhalb von 1000 Meter kräftige
Schneefälle und auch in den östlichen
Mittelgebirge man sieht es hier die
Wolken der Niederschlag staut sich an
den Bergen und dementsprechend schneit
es kräftig nach Westen hin ist es eher
Regen in der Nacht also kräftige
Schneefälle in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen und an den im Westen
regnet es an den Küsten gibt es noch
Sturm das lässt allmählich nach bei
tiefsten Temperaturen von -1° im
Vogtland und 7 Grad ganz im Westen
Deutschlands ja und morgen dann weiterer
Schnee in den Bergen und vor allem an
den Alpen teils ergiebig nach Nordosten
hin zeigt sich die Sonne und da wird es
auch etwas ruhiger der Wind ist nicht
mehr so stark bei höchsten Temperaturen
von 0 Grad im Vogtland und 9 Grad
ziemlich Milz im Westen die nächsten
Tage wechselhaft geht's weiter mit Regen
und Schnee an den alten mal drei bis
zehn Grad und vor allem der Sonntag wird
sehr durchwachsen bei 1 bis 8 Grad ein
schöner Abend
Sabine Leutheuser Schnarrenberger wird
heute bei uns zu Gast sein wir freuen
uns außerdem auf die Vorsitzende des
Deutschen Richterbundes Andrea Titz auf
den Politikwissenschaftler Hamed